on a décidé de tenter aujourd'hui un
challenge dont tout le monde parle un
ami des produits laitiers qu'on adore
moi je vous dis les produits laitiers jo
tista son jeu qui fait que j'ai déjà
dans le fromage j'adore les yaourts
j'adore la d'année j'adore les qui rit
j'adore les bannis vais là-bas babybel
tout ça en plus après avec les baby mais
je fais comme ça des boules rouges comme
ça et que je cite comme ça son livre n
ait à peut-être que ma mère moi mon fils
un jour il m'a dit j'ai pas dis j'ai
pris 200 babybel je suis fait des billes
rouges comme ça dans ma vie j'ai mangé
tous les bonheurs des bougies avaient
accès peut faire des bougies avec
exactement quoi faire de bonnes choses
avec nos bébelles nez rouge mais on peut
surtout on peut faire des nids roule
vraiment pas tarder à me faire chier
est ce qu'on connaissait le mic pong le
meeting challenge cette pression pour
garder mon ami michou l'a fait alors je
sais pas combien d'amis de temps pour
réussir ce que j'ai essayé la ccva la
très très dur et si j'arrivais à faire
le mick channon gars mais bon on entre
dans l'américain lors du tir si je
réussi donc à mettre la balle c'est très
simple il faut que je fasse rebondir la
balle qu'elle a fait s'arrêter quand
c'est chaud c'est pratiquement
impossible d'offrir un week end au
soleil pour deux personnes à nous à tout
le public
[Applaudissements]
si les racines je rate je veux dire on
va dire que j'aurais 15 chance assez
bien car c'est beaucoup apprécié j'ai
fait trois fois c'est impossible il faut
c'est pas joli en revanche si je n'y
arrive pas vous irez tous en week end
pour 2 personnes aura fera chez nicolas
pernikoff regarde et me choix réussissez
pas qu'on mette pas la même et me soit
réussie regarde grand jour aujourd'hui
je prends ma revanche 1000 points
challenge sauf que cette fois ci on va y
arriver moi je te le dis mon grand bruit
[Musique]
mais rentre
[Applaudissements]
je rappelle enfin si j'arrive à la m way
week end pour deux personnes au soleil
vous le dis pour deux personnes un week
end ouf et non si je rate pas de
week-end tout le monde rentre chez soi
il est 19 heures 2 on est en direct le
film que chercher ces prisoner ça va
être bien tim de ouf parce qu'on s'est
tous demandé ce qu'on ferait ah ouais
allez c'est parti
ah non c'est trop dur à battre envie de
chéri allez dire
il a assez d'être
[Applaudissements]
aïe aïe aïe
et
mais voilà enfin éprouvent le groupe
berger ici michaud
val à mermet shota 6 mai soit plus déçu
il a asséné devant la tournée que je
peux vous demander un truc je vous
pouvez vraiment faire des décotes même
chasse si vous voulez c'est trop dur
meiway et ses proches la veille sur eux
mêmes conditions mais je me demande s'il
peut pas mener la balance et adultes de
la force
ils ont collé la bouteille et son côté
voit bien on va dire qu'il m'en reste
sain qui voit là je joue pour le public
vas-y aller concentre toi tellement dur
échec pense que tu aimes le lait 107 m
comme le carnet week-end je vous dis
tout de suite je suis aperta jusqu'à 22
heures
[Applaudissements]
m
et
je
or
ça vaut pas mieux que tu ne tueras pas
conseil de classe ce soit un coup fumant
arrive on y arrive ce matin calme toi
quand même temps c'est mon esprit de
vous énerver
c'est vous qui mérite donc sa première
émission de télé bon alors là les
magnifiques messieurs durée 1h10 il
reste encore un mini match parce qu'on
peut essayer nous écoutent les boules
par perdre si j'arrive à me croyais
vraiment jamais si je barrier vous n'y
arrivez pas vous motiver leur avis
conforme à ses 50 foutraque handball
ouais c'est fait c'est ça qu'il faut
j'ai tout sur la légendaire finale et
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
non
dans les accords
[Musique]
étant là
le temps
[Musique]
m
c'est leur vélo
comme en mai
non non mais c'est quand même ce que je
suis convaincu
c est ce qui est vraiment énorme et
votre motivation est vraiment énorme
c'est qu'à part du moment où il ya un
pari et de l'eau via la clé là vous
gagnez 3 boules c'était réglé 50
battront soir vous avez gagné vous avez
mois nous faire chier ce soir